- Selamat datang kembali di Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Nama saya John Watrous, dan
saya adalah Technical Director untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran keempat dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran
terakhir di unit pertama seri tentang dasar-dasar
informasi kuantum.
Sejauh ini, kita sudah membahas
bagaimana informasi kuantum bekerja untuk sistem tunggal maupun sistem ganda, kita sudah melihat
model quantum circuit,
dan kita sudah mengamati beberapa
keterbatasan mendasar pada informasi kuantum.
Di sepanjang jalan, kita
menemukan beberapa konsep matematika penting
termasuk tensor product dan inner product, dan kita akan terus
menggunakan konsep-konsep itu dan akan memperkenalkan beberapa
konsep baru sesuai kebutuhan.
Di pelajaran ini, kita akan
fokus pada tiga contoh penting yang mendasar, yaitu quantum teleportation, superdense coding, dan permainan CHSH,
yang juga disebut pertidaksamaan CHSH dan tidak selalu digambarkan sebagai permainan.
Ini bukan sekadar contoh acak
yang dimaksudkan untuk mengilustrasikan cara kerja informasi kuantum, ini benar-benar merupakan bagian
kunci dari fondasi
informasi kuantum dan
muncul dalam berbagai setting yang berbeda dan kadang tak terduga dalam informasi kuantum
dan komputasi.
Entanglement memainkan peran kunci dalam ketiga
contoh ini, dan faktanya, entanglement itulah yang membuatnya bekerja
dan membuatnya menarik. Jadi, pelajaran ini akan, dalam artian tertentu, menjadi kesempatan pertama kita untuk
melihat entanglement beraksi
dan mulai mengeksplorasi apa yang membuat entanglement begitu menarik.
Gambaran umum pelajaran ini
sangat sederhana, kita akan membahas satu per satu
ketiga contoh yang baru saja saya sebutkan,
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding, dan permainan CHSH.
Kita akan membahas apa saja hal-hal ini dan apa yang membuatnya menarik serta kita akan melalui analisis yang menjelaskan secara tepat bagaimana cara kerjanya
di level matematis.
Sebelum kita masuk ke contoh
pertama dari tiga contoh tersebut, yaitu quantum teleportation, ada baiknya kita memperkenalkan dulu tokoh-tokohnya,
Alice dan Bob, kalau kamu
belum familiar dengan mereka.
Alice dan Bob, adalah nama
yang diberikan kepada entitas atau agen hipotetis dalam sistem, protokol, permainan,
dan benar-benar semua jenis interaksi lain yang mungkin ingin kamu pertimbangkan yang melibatkan pertukaran informasi.
Mereka pertama kali muncul dalam
konteks kriptografi di tahun 1970-an, tapi
konvensi penggunaan nama-nama ini dengan cara seperti ini sudah menjadi sangat umum
dalam konteks yang jauh lebih luas sejak saat itu. Idenya adalah bahwa ini
adalah nama yang sangat umum, setidaknya di beberapa bagian dunia, dan mereka dimulai dengan huruf A dan B,
dan juga praktis
untuk merujuk ke Alice dan Bob menggunakan kata ganti, dia (perempuan) dan dia (laki-laki) demi keringkasan.
Kita biasanya membayangkan bahwa Alice dan Bob berada di lokasi yang berbeda dan bahwa mereka memiliki
tujuan serta perilaku yang berbeda
tergantung pada apa pun yang sedang kita bicarakan.
Misalnya, kalau kita
berbicara tentang komunikasi, yaitu transmisi informasi, maka kita mungkin memutuskan
bahwa Alice adalah pengirim
dan Bob adalah penerima
dari informasi apa pun yang sedang ditransmisikan.
Kadang Alice dan Bob
bekerja sama, itu sangat umum, tapi kadang mereka
bersaing atau bisa punya tujuan berbeda yang mungkin
atau mungkin tidak konsisten
satu sama lain, tapi
semua itu harus dijelaskan dengan jelas dalam situasi yang ada.
Tentu saja, mereka mewakili abstraksi dan tidak harus berupa manusia nyata.
Kita juga bisa memperkenalkan
karakter tambahan seperti Charlie dan
Diane atau nama-nama berbeda yang mewakili persona berbeda seperti Eve
untuk penyadap atau Mallory untuk seseorang yang bertindak jahat
tergantung pada situasinya.
Bagaimanapun, kita akan melihat Alice dan Bob di ketiga
contoh yang akan kita bahas dalam pelajaran ini dan dari waktu ke waktu
sepanjang sisa seri. Saya juga akan membuat beberapa
komentar tentang entanglement sebelum beralih ke tiga contoh tersebut.
Dalam pelajaran dua, kita menemukan contoh ini dari state terjalin dari dua qubit.
Ini adalah salah satu dari empat Bell state, dan kamu bisa bilang bahwa
state tertentu ini merupakan contoh arketipal
dari state kuantum yang terjalin.
Kita juga menemukan
contoh ini dari state probabilistik dua bit.
Ini analog dengan
state terjalin dalam arti tertentu, tapi tidak terjalin,
entanglement adalah fenomena yang secara unik
bersifat kuantum,
pada dasarnya berdasarkan definisi.
Ada definisi matematis yang tepat tentang apa itu entanglement dan pada dasarnya apa yang dikatakan definisi itu adalah bahwa entanglement
adalah korelasi kuantum non-klasikal.
Tapi itu tidak terlalu
membantu di level intuitif, ini adalah definisi entanglement dalam hal apa yang bukan entanglement,
dan mungkin karena alasan itulah memang cukup sulit untuk menjelaskan apa itu entanglement dan apa yang membuatnya istimewa
dalam istilah intuitif.
Ketika orang-orang mencoba
menjelaskan apa itu entanglement dalam istilah intuitif,
kamu sering mendengar penjelasan yang benar-benar tidak
membedakan kedua state ini
dengan cara yang bermakna. Kamu mungkin mendengar gagasan
bahwa jika kamu mengukur salah satu dari dua qubit yang terjalin,
maka state dari yang lainnya
WEBVTT
entah bagaimana langsung terpengaruh atau bahwa state dua qubit itu tidak bisa dideskripsikan secara terpisah
atau bahwa dua qubit itu
entah bagaimana memiliki memori satu sama lain atau bahkan bahwa
mereka terikat secara emosional.
Tapi kenapa sifat-sifat itu
tidak berlaku untuk state ini?
Dua bit ini sangat erat terhubung, masing-masing memiliki memori sempurna tentang yang lainnya dalam artian harfiah, tapi
ini bukan state yang terjalin.
Salah satu cara untuk menjelaskan apa yang membuat entanglement istimewa dan apa yang membuat state ini
sangat berbeda dari state itu adalah dengan menjelaskan apa yang
bisa kita lakukan dengan entanglement
atau apa yang bisa kita lihat terjadi
karena entanglement yang melampaui keputusan yang kita buat tentang cara kita merepresentasikan
pengetahuan kita menggunakan vektor.
Ketiga contoh
yang akan kita bahas dalam pelajaran ini memiliki sifat ini dalam artian bahwa mereka mengilustrasikan
hal-hal yang bisa kita lakukan dengan entanglement yang tidak
bisa kita lakukan dengan state ini
atau dengan state yang berkorelasi secara klasikal mana pun.
Memang, sangat umum dalam studi informasi dan komputasi kuantum bahwa kita memandang entanglement sebagai sumber daya
yang melaluinya berbagai tugas
dapat diselesaikan.
Dan ketika kita melakukan itu, kita memandang state ini sebagai mewakili
satu unit entanglement.
Kita menyebut unit entanglement ini sebagai e-bit, huruf e singkatan dari
entangled atau entanglement.
Memang benar bahwa ini adalah dua qubit, tapi sebagai kuantitas
entanglement, ini adalah satu e-bit.
Kamu juga bisa memandang sepasang
bit klasikal biasa dalam state probabilistik berkorelasi dari sebelumnya sebagai sumber daya yang merupakan
satu bit randomness bersama.
Ini bisa sangat berguna dalam
kriptografi untuk berbagi bit acak dengan seseorang dengan asumsi
bahwa tidak ada orang lain yang tahu apa bit itu sehingga bisa
digunakan sebagai kunci privat
atau sebagai bagian dari kunci privat, misalnya, untuk tujuan enkripsi.
Tapi dalam pelajaran ini, fokus kita akan ada pada state terjalin ini dan
hal-hal yang bisa kita lakukan dengannya.
Dan sekadar memperjelas terminologi, ketika kita bilang bahwa Alice
dan Bob berbagi e-bit, maksudnya adalah bahwa
Alice punya qubit bernama A,
Bob punya qubit bernama B, dan bersama-sama pasangan A, B
berada dalam state Phi plus.
Tidak penting nama apa yang
kita pilih untuk dua qubit itu, tentu saja, kita bisa
memilih nama yang berbeda, tapi sepanjang pelajaran ini,
kita akan menggunakan nama-nama ini
demi kejelasan. Contoh pertama dari pelajaran ini
adalah quantum teleportation,
yang selanjutnya akan kita sebut
sebagai teleportation saja demi keringkasan.
Teleportation adalah protokol yang memungkinkan pengirim untuk
mentransmisikan informasi kuantum ke penerima hanya menggunakan entanglement
dan komunikasi klasikal untuk
mencapai transmisi tersebut.
Ini tidak ada hubungannya sama sekali dengan interpretasi umum
kata teleportation dalam fiksi ilmiah, yaitu bahwa materi menghilang
di satu lokasi dan muncul di lokasi lain.
Quantum teleportation hanyalah nama yang dimaksudkan untuk membangkitkan gambaran itu atau sebagai metafora.
Yang ditelportasi adalah
informasi kuantum bukan materi, dan itu terjadi
melalui transmisi informasi klasikal
bersama dengan entanglement.
Untuk memahami secara tepat
bagaimana teleportation bekerja, ada baiknya kita mulai dengan
menyiapkan panggungnya, begitu katanya.
Yang akan kita lakukan adalah membayangkan sebuah skenario yang melibatkan Alice dan Bob dan
skenarionya adalah sebagai berikut,
Alice punya qubit bernama Q yang
ingin dia transmisikan ke Bob, artinya dia
ingin Bob memegang di tangannya
sebuah qubit yang berada di
state yang persis sama dengan state Q saat mereka memulai protokol.
Dengan kata lain, kita berbicara tentang masalah mendasar dari
transmisi informasi atau komunikasi.
Kita punya pengirim bernama Alice
dan penerima bernama Bob dan Alice ingin mengirim
informasi kuantum dalam bentuk qubit ke Bob.
Ada sebuah batasan, yaitu bahwa Alice tidak
bisa secara fisik mengirim Q ke Bob, yang bisa dia lakukan hanyalah mengirim informasi klasikal ke Bob.
Alice dan Bob juga punya
sumber daya tambahan, yaitu bahwa mereka berbagi e-bit.
Jadi itulah skenarionya, mudah untuk membayangkan situasi di mana batasan bahwa
Alice tidak bisa secara fisik mengirim Q
ke Bob adalah abstraksi yang wajar.
Kalau Alice dan Bob berada di
benua yang berbeda misalnya, atau kalau Alice tidak tahu
lokasi tepat Bob, maka secara fisik mengirim qubit
mungkin akan cukup menantang.
Tapi komunikasi klasikal
tentu saja tidak hanya mungkin tapi juga cukup murah
dalam keadaan tersebut.
Sekarang, seseorang mungkin bertanya apakah mungkin bagi Alice dan Bob untuk menyelesaikan tugas ini tanpa perlu e-bit bersama.
Dengan kata lain, adakah
cara untuk mentransmisikan qubit menggunakan komunikasi klasikal
saja?
Jawabannya tidak, tidak mungkin mentransmisikan informasi kuantum menggunakan komunikasi klasikal saja, dan itu tidak terlalu sulit untuk dibuktikan
menggunakan beberapa teori informasi kuantum dasar, yang akan kita lihat di
unit ketiga seri.
Untuk sekarang, cara intuitif
untuk memikirkannya adalah dengan memikirkan teorema no-cloning.
WEBVTT
Bayangkan ada cara
untuk mengirim informasi kuantum menggunakan komunikasi klasikal saja,
tapi komunikasi klasikal
bisa dengan mudah disalin dan disebarluaskan, jadi itu berarti
komunikasi klasikal
bisa disebarluaskan ke dua
penerima, Bob dan Charlie, misalnya.
Kalau keduanya menerima
informasi klasikal yang sama dari Alice, maka apakah
keduanya akan berakhir dengan Q?
Itu akan menyarankan bahwa kita mengkloning Q, tapi kita tahu bahwa itu tidak mungkin.
Sekadar catatan sampingan, mari kita
perhatikan bahwa tentu saja mungkin untuk mendeskripsikan
vektor state kuantum menggunakan informasi klasikal.
Setiap vektor state kuantum
yang akan kamu lihat dalam seri ini sedang dideskripsikan kepadamu
menggunakan informasi klasikal yang ditransmisikan ke perangkat
apa pun yang kamu tonton.
Secara umum, kita bisa membayangkan
mendeskripsikan state apa pun yang Q ada di dalamnya menggunakan bit klasikal
mungkin dengan beberapa presisi,
tapi itu bukan komunikasi kuantum, itu hanya mendeskripsikan
state kuantum sebagai vektor, dan kita akan kembali ke
perbedaan di antara keduanya
dalam sebentar.
Kembali ke skenarionya, dan bekerja di bawah
asumsi bahwa Alice dan Bob memang berbagi e-bit, kita akan
melihat bahwa Alice dan Bob
memiliki semua yang mereka butuhkan
untuk menyelesaikan tugas, dan itulah yang dilakukan protokol quantum
teleportation, khususnya menggunakan dua bit
komunikasi klasikal.
sebelum masuk ke
detail-detail ini, izinkan saya membuat beberapa catatan singkat
hanya untuk memastikan bahwa asumsi-asumsinya jelas.
Pertama, kita mengasumsikan
di sini bahwa state Q tidak diketahui oleh Alice dan
Bob, jadi khususnya,
Alice tidak bisa mengirim Bob
deskripsi state Q karena dia umumnya tidak mengetahuinya.
Kita juga harus mempertimbangkan kemungkinan bahwa Q berkorelasi dengan sistem lain, termasuk kemungkinan
bahwa itu terjalin
dengan sistem lain dan
transmisi qubit ini ke Bob harus mempertahankan korelasi-korelasi itu.
Terakhir, saya menyebutkan
teorema no-cloning ketika saya berbicara tentang
mencoba mengomunikasikan qubit secara klasikal, tapi
ada koneksi lain di sini
dengan teorema no-cloning, yaitu bahwa jika Bob
menerima transmisi qubit Q ini dari Alice,
maka dia tidak boleh memilikinya lagi
karena Q tidak bisa dikloning, dan itu hanya sesuatu yang perlu diingat
saat kita mempertimbangkan protokol teleportation.
Protokol teleportation
bisa dideskripsikan dengan cara yang cukup sederhana dan langsung dengan diagram quantum circuit seperti yang bisa kamu lihat di sini.
Ini sedikit distilasi dalam
artian bahwa ia menggambarkan pemisahan antara bagian Alice dan bagian Bob, tapi selain itu, ini hanyalah
diagram quantum circuit,
semua yang ada di atas garis putus-putus mewakili tindakan Alice dan semua yang di bawah
mewakili tindakan Bob.
Waktu berjalan dari kiri ke kanan seperti biasa, dan kita melihat bahwa kita mulai
dengan dua qubit ini di sini dalam state Phi plus,
jadi ini adalah e-bit
yang Alice dan Bob mulai dengannya.
Kita bisa memberi label pada qubit untuk memperjelas mana
yang mana, jadi ini adalah qubit A, dan ini adalah qubit
B yang membentuk e-bit,
dan ini adalah qubit Q yang
ingin Alice transmisikan ke Bob.
Di sini kita berhipotesis bahwa
state qubit Q ini adalah Psi, tapi sedikit lebih lanjut kita akan mempertimbangkan kemungkinan
bahwa Q terjalin
dengan beberapa sistem lain. Dan apa yang diagram klaim karena kita sudah menuliskan psi di sini,
adalah bahwa circuit ini
secara efektif mentransmisikan state psi apa pun yang kita miliki
di sini di bagian Alice ke sini di bagian Bob,
satu-satunya komunikasi
yang kita miliki yang melewati
garis antara Alice dan Bob adalah dua bit klasikal yang diwakili oleh garis ganda ini di sini.
Mari kita perkecil
diagram ini sedikit supaya kita punya sedikit lebih banyak ruang dan mari kita periksa
circuit ini lebih dekat.
Saya sudah mendeskripsikan
kondisi awal, tapi sekadar rekap, Alice memegang qubit A
dan Bob memegang qubit B,
di mana A dan B bersama-sama
berada dalam state Phi plus, jadi itulah artinya berbagi e-bit.
Alice juga punya qubit Q ini yang ingin dia transmisikan ke Bob, dan kita sedang mempertimbangkan kasus bahwa Q berada dalam beberapa state kuantum arbitrer Psi.
Sekarang, kita tidak tahu apa pun
tentang bagaimana Alice dan Bob mendapatkan e-bit ini.
Bisa jadi mereka sudah
memilikinya untuk waktu yang lama, mungkin mereka membuatnya beberapa waktu lalu ketika mereka berada di lokasi yang sama
dan mereka sudah menyimpannya
untuk kesempatan ini, tapi detail-detail itu tidak relevan di sini.
Langkah-langkah yang terjadi selanjutnya, yang mewakili
protokol teleportation itu sendiri adalah sebagai berikut, dan sekadar kejelasan,
ini adalah langkah-langkah yang
diagram deskripsikan dan kita hanya akan
menuliskannya dalam kata-kata supaya jelas apa yang
diagram ekspresikan.
Alice pertama melakukan
operasi controlled-NOT di mana qubit Q yang
ingin dia kirimkan ke Bob adalah kontrol dan
qubit A adalah target.
Langkah selanjutnya adalah bahwa dia
melakukan operasi Hadamard pada Q, dan kemudian dia mengukur
dua qubit yang dia pegang,
A dan Q terhadap
pengukuran basis standar dan kita membiarkan huruf kecil a sebagai hasil pengukuran qubit A,
WEBVTT
dan kita membiarkan huruf kecil b sebagai hasil pengukuran qubit Q.
Alice kemudian mengirimkan
dua bit klasikal itu ke Bob dan ini adalah satu-satunya komunikasi yang terlibat dalam protokol ini dan itu ditunjukkan dalam diagram
oleh fakta bahwa dua bit ini
melewati garis putus-putus antara Alice dan Bob,
yang bisa kamu anggap sebagai mewakili jarak apa pun
yang memisahkan mereka.
Setelah Bob menerima bit
a dan b, dia melakukan dua hal.
Pertama, jika a sama dengan satu, maka dia melakukan operasi X
atau dengan kata lain, NOT gate pada qubit B-nya,
dan kalau tidak, jika a sama dengan nol, maka dia tidak melakukan itu.
Dan dengan cara yang sama,
jika b sama dengan satu, maka Bob melakukan operasi Z
atau Z-gate atau pembalikan fasa
juga pada qubit b dan seperti
sebelumnya, jika b sama dengan nol, maka dia tidak melakukan itu.
Semua ini ditunjukkan dalam gambar di mana kita punya gate controlled-X
dan controlled-Z ini di mana kontrolnya adalah
dua bit klasikal.
Kamu tidak harus menganggap gate-gate ini sebagai control gate
kalau tidak mau, ini hanyalah cara yang praktis
untuk mengekspresikan apa yang kita inginkan
dalam bentuk diagram circuit. Intinya adalah bahwa Bob menerapkan
X-gate ke qubit b jika a sama dengan satu dan
kemudian dia menerapkan Z-gate
ke qubit b jika B sama dengan satu.
Dan demi kenyamanan nanti kita bisa menuliskan secara eksplisit
operasi gabungan yang Bob lakukan pada qubit b-nya,
tergantung pada bit klasikal
yang Alice kirimkan.
Jadi itulah protokol teleportation, cukup sederhana sebenarnya, bahwa
ia benar-benar bekerja adalah hal yang berbeda
dan meskipun analisisnya
tidak terlalu rumit,
kamu tidak perlu merasa bahwa kamu melewatkan sesuatu jika kamu tidak langsung melihat mengapa ia bekerja.
Itulah mengapa kita perlu
melalui analisis dan itulah yang akan kita lakukan selanjutnya.
Untuk menganalisis protokol teleportation, kita akan menjalaninya langkah demi langkah untuk melihat apa state
dari tiga qubit di berbagai titik waktu.
Kita akan pertama mempertimbangkan
kasus bahwa qubit teratas berada dalam state AlphaNol plus beta satu, di mana alpha dan beta
adalah bilangan kompleks apa pun
yang membuat vektor ini
menjadi vektor satuan.
Ini adalah qubit Q yang
Alice coba transmisikan, tapi kita tidak benar-benar peduli apa
namanya saat ini.
Sedikit lebih lanjut, kita akan
melihat situasi di mana qubit ini terjalin dengan sistem lain, tapi ini adalah titik awal yang bagus hanya untuk menjaga agar hal-hal tetap sederhana
dan untuk melihat bagaimana analisisnya
bekerja dengan lebih jelas.
Kalau kita pertimbangkan state dari
ketiga qubit bersama-sama di sini di awal, kita melihat
bahwa state ini memiliki bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dua qubit pertama berada
dalam state Phi plus, qubit ketiga adalah yang teratas
sesuai konvensi
untuk mengurutkan qubit yang
saya deskripsikan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, dan jadi kita mengambil tensor product untuk mendapatkan state dari
ketiga qubit bersama-sama.
Kita bisa memperluas ekspresi ini
dengan terlebih dahulu mensubstitusi definisi state Phi plus dan kemudian menghitung tensor product
dan kita mendapatkan state
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Ini tidak selalu strategi terbaik
ngomong-ngomong, untuk sepenuhnya memperluas
sebuah vektor seperti ini, secara umum sebaiknya menunggu sampai
kamu punya alasan yang bagus untuk melakukan ini.
Tapi di sini kita memang punya alasan, yaitu bahwa kita ingin
menghitung aksi dari controlled NOT gate ini dan dengan menuliskan state dalam bentuk ini,
kita bisa melakukannya dengan sangat mudah.
Dan khususnya, ini adalah
state dari tiga qubit setelah controlled NOT gate diterapkan.
Qubit ketiga adalah qubit kontrol karena itu
adalah yang ada di atas berdasarkan konvensi kita, dan qubit kedua,
yang merupakan yang di tengah,
adalah targetnya, jadi kita hanya
mengoperasikan kets sesuai itu, jika bit ketiga adalah
nol, tidak ada yang terjadi,
dan jika bit ketiga adalah satu,
maka kita membalik bit kedua.
Kemudian kita melakukan Hadamard
gate pada qubit ketiga, kita bisa menuliskan vektor yang dihasilkan seperti yang bisa kamu lihat
di sini dengan mensubstitusi
state plus dan minus untuk state nol dan satu.
Dan kalau kita mau punya cukup
ruang untuk memperluas yang ini, kita harus memperkecilnya sedikit dan sekarang, dengan mensubstitusi state
plus dan minus
dengan definisi mereka,
membawa akar kuadrat dua ke penyebut, kita mendapatkan state yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dan dengan memperluas itu, kita mendapatkan state yang kamu lihat di sini.
Jadi, itulah state dari tiga qubit setelah Alice melakukan dua operasinya.
Alice kemudian mengukur
dan jika kita ingin menganalisis pengukuran, yang kita lakukan adalah mengisolasi vektor basis standar
untuk sistem yang diukur
seperti yang kita bicarakan dalam pelajaran dua, dan jika kita melakukan itu dalam kasus tertentu ini, inilah yang kita peroleh.
Dan jika kamu melihat
ekspresi itu sejenak, mungkin tampak sedikit aneh karena sekarang tampak seperti qubit pertama,
yang merupakan qubit terbawah
entah bagaimana bergantung pada alpha dan beta, meskipun
pada titik ini belum ada komunikasi melintasi garis putus-putus,
WEBVTT
tapi itu hanyalah ilusi. Ingat bahwa skalar bergerak bebas
melalui tensor product, jadi sebenarnya tidak ada artinya bahwa alpha dan beta
dikaitkan dengan qubit pertama.
Yang benar-benar kita lakukan
di sini adalah menggunakan tanda kurung sesuai dengan
multilinearitas tensor product.
Bagaimanapun, itulah bentuk yang kita butuhkan untuk melihat apa yang pengukuran lakukan, dan kita bisa melihat satu
hal menarik segera
yaitu bahwa probabilitas dari empat kemungkinan hasil pengukuran selalu seragam.
Probabilitas untuk mengukur masing-masing
pasangan hasil pengukuran adalah seperempat, jadi, khususnya,
tidak ada ketergantungan
sama sekali pada alpha dan beta.
Kita bisa melihat itu dalam setiap kasus dengan menghitung norma Euclidean kuadrat dari
vektor apa pun yang di-tensor ke vektor basis standar
yang kita isolasi,
dan dalam setiap kasus kita punya seperempat yang kita dapatkan dengan mengkuadratkan satu setengah kali nilai absolut kuadrat dari alpha
plus nilai absolut
kuadrat dari beta, yang adalah satu, dan jadi kita mendapatkan seperempat di setiap kasus.
Cukup penting sebenarnya
bahwa probabilitas dari hasil-hasil berbeda ini tidak bergantung dengan cara apa pun pada qubit yang
Alice ingin transmisikan.
Kita tidak bisa memiliki bahwa state arbitrer masuk di sini dan keluar di bawah sini dan namun pengukuran mengungkapkan
informasi tentang state tersebut.
Kalau kamu ingin mendapatkan informasi tentang state kuantum arbitrer, kamu harus mengganggu
state tersebut secara umum.
Ini adalah tabel yang mendeskripsikan tidak hanya probabilitas
dari berbagai hasil, tapi juga state dari
tiga qubit bersama-sama
yang dikondisikan pada setiap kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran.
Kita mendapatkan ini dengan menormalisasi vektor-vektor yang di-tensor ke berbagai
state basis standar, tapi itu mudah dalam kasus ini,
kita hanya menghilangkan faktor satu setengah untuk mendapatkan vektor satuan.
Jadi, apa yang kita miliki segera
setelah Alice mengukur adalah bahwa Alice memiliki dua bit acak yang seragam dan itu saja.
Khususnya, dia tidak lagi
memiliki state asli dan dia tidak memiliki
informasi apa pun tentangnya, dia hanya memiliki bit acak.
State Bob sekarang memang
bergantung pada alpha dan beta serta pada hasil pengukuran.
Kalau kita bayangkan sebentar
bahwa Alice belum mengirimkan hasil pengukuran
sehingga Bob tidak tahu apa hasil pengukurannya,
maka dia tidak akan dapat
mendapatkan informasi apa pun tentang alpha dan beta
dari mengukur qubitnya.
Empat kemungkinan
yang kita miliki di sini sudah cukup tersebar untuk memastikan bahwa tidak ada informasi
tentang alpha dan beta
yang bisa pernah diperoleh
melalui pengukuran. Itu harus benar di level intuitif karena jika tidak kita akan mendapatkan
komunikasi lebih cepat dari cahaya.
Alice jelas tidak bisa
mentransmisikan informasi ke Bob tanpa mengirimkan apa pun sama sekali, tapi tentu saja Alice memang
mengirimkan hasil pengukuran
ke Bob, jadi mari kita perluas tabelnya untuk melihat apa yang terjadi ketika
Bob melakukan operasi-operasinya.
Dalam kolom ini di sini, kita punya berbagai operasi yang secara efektif Bob lakukan untuk setiap kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran
seperti yang kita amati sebelumnya,
dan jika kita menjalaninya satu per satu dan kita menerapkan
operasi itu ke qubit Bob, yang merupakan qubit pertama, B,
kita melihat bahwa kita mendapatkan hasil yang sama
di semua empat kasus dan hasil itu adalah state aslinya.
Jadi, state asli dari qubit Q berhasil ditelportasi ke B.
Kalau Bob ingin mengganti nama qubitnya dan menyebutnya Q pada titik ini, dia tentu bisa melakukan itu, tapi intinya adalah bahwa sekarang
dia memegang state asli
yang Alice miliki dan tentu saja secara keharusan, Alice tidak memilikinya lagi.
Perhatikan juga bahwa e-bit
secara efektif sudah habis digunakan melalui proses ini,
teleportation memiliki biaya
dan biayanya adalah satu e-bit dan dua bit klasikal komunikasi, dan ketika protokol
selesai, e-bit sudah habis.
Kita sekarang sudah menetapkan bahwa
protokol teleportation bekerja dengan benar di bawah asumsi bahwa qubit teratas berada dalam state kuantum
berbentuk alpha kali ket
nol plus beta kali ket satu.
Tapi apa yang terjadi jika
qubit teratas terjalin dengan beberapa sistem lain seperti
salah satu qubit tambahan kita
seperti yang kita miliki di layar ini? Kita mungkin ingin menggunakan teleportation
dalam keadaan seperti itu.
Mungkin Alice dan Bob sebenarnya
berencana untuk melakukan teleportation 100 kali sehingga Alice bisa mentransmisikan
register kuantum 100 qubit
ke Bob, satu qubit sekaligus.
Atau mungkin qubit-qubit tambahan ini
bahkan tidak berada dalam kepemilikan Alice sama sekali
dan orang lain memilikinya, mungkin Alice bahkan tidak
tahu bahwa mereka ada.
Pertanyaannya adalah, apakah
teleportation masih bekerja meskipun qubit yang sedang ditelportasi terjalin dengan sistem lain?
Di sini, state dari qubit Q bersama dengan sistem tambahan
yang kita pertimbangkan diekspresikan seperti yang bisa kamu lihat di sini
di mana gamma nol dan
gamma satu adalah vektor satuan yang mewakili state kuantum
dari sistem tambahan ini.
Kita selalu bisa menuliskan state arbitrer dari sistem gabungan dengan cara ini.
Kita sebenarnya bahkan tidak
perlu alpha dan beta di sini, tapi jika kita menyertakannya,
maka kita bisa mengambil gamma nol dan gamma satu sebagai vektor satuan
dan itu akan membuat
koneksi ke kasus yang lebih sederhana yang sudah kita pertimbangkan lebih transparan.
WEBVTT
Kita bisa melalui
analisis yang mirip dengan yang sudah kita jalani, tapi di mana kita juga melacak
sistem tambahan ini.
Ini sedikit lebih berantakan karena kita punya sistem tambahan, tapi
idenya persis sama, ini adalah ringkasan singkat.
Ini adalah state awal, ini adalah state setelah
controlled NOT gate,
dan ini adalah state setelah
operasi Hadamard.
Kalau kita perluas hal-hal ini,
kita bisa mengekspresikan state itu seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
itulah state segera
sebelum pengukuran Alice, dan jika kita menjalani
kemungkinan-kemungkinan seperti sebelumnya
dan kita pertimbangkan apa
yang terjadi ketika Bob menerapkan operasi apa pun yang seharusnya dia terapkan,
maka kita menemukan bahwa memang
state yang benar keluar dan protokol bekerja seperti yang diharapkan.
Dalam tabel ini ngomong-ngomong, kita menggunakan huruf R untuk
merujuk ke sistem tambahan ini, dan kamu bisa melihat bahwa kita menggunakan trik yang cukup sederhana,
yaitu memutuskan bahwa kita lebih suka, setidaknya sementara, mengurutkan
sistem sebagai B, R, A, Q
karena itu lebih mudah untuk menuliskan state-state di sini.
Berdasarkan diagram, sistem seharusnya diurutkan sebagai B, A, Q, R,
tapi selama kita membuatnya jelas, kita bisa memilih
pengurutan yang berbeda yang lebih mudah.
Singkatnya, semua yang terjadi dalam analisis ini adalah
hal yang sama dengan yang terjadi dalam analisis yang lebih sederhana,
tapi kita kebetulan memiliki
vektor-vektor tambahan ini, gamma nol dan gamma satu
yang pada dasarnya ikut menumpang.
Kita selalu punya gamma nol
ketika ada faktor alpha dan gamma satu ketika
ada faktor beta dan pada akhirnya,
semuanya bekerja dengan benar.
Ini sebenarnya tidak mengejutkan sama sekali, kita punya proses fisik yang bertindak seperti operasi identitas pada qubit
dalam state kuantum arbitrer, dan hanya ada satu
cara untuk itu bisa terjadi dan itu adalah bahwa operasinya
adalah operasi identitas.
Itu sedikit lebih mudah dijelaskan menggunakan formulasi umum
dari informasi kuantum, tapi intinya adalah bahwa berdasarkan linieritas,
kita sebenarnya tidak perlu melalui analisis tambahan ini.
Begitu kita tahu bahwa
teleportation bekerja dengan benar untuk qubit tunggal yang terisolasi, kita bisa menyimpulkan bahwa hanya ada
satu kemungkinan
yang dapat mendeskripsikan apa yang protokol lakukan, dan itu adalah bahwa ia mengimplementasikan
operasi identitas di mana qubit masuk di sini
dan keluar di sini, secara efektif bertindak sebagai saluran kuantum yang sempurna
dan tanpa noise.
Hanya beberapa catatan singkat
tentang teleportation sebelum beralih ke
contoh kedua dari pelajaran, yaitu superdense coding.
Pertama, saya pikir penting untuk memperjelas bahwa teleportation bukan aplikasi dari informasi kuantum, ia adalah protokol
dan khususnya ia adalah
protokol untuk melakukan komunikasi kuantum.
Agar teleportation
seperti yang saya deskripsikan menjadi berguna, harus ada alasan untuk melakukan komunikasi kuantum.
Kedua, masuk akal untuk berspekulasi bahwa teleportation bisa, suatu
hari, menjadi cara standar
untuk mengomunikasikan informasi kuantum, dan khususnya sebuah proses yang dikenal sebagai entanglement distillation
berpotensi bisa digunakan
sebagai cara untuk mengomunikasikan qubit secara andal. Kalau Alice dan Bob tahu mereka akan mengomunikasikan informasi kuantum atau mereka
membutuhkan untuk mengomunikasikan
informasi kuantum, maka proses entanglement distillation ini
bisa digunakan untuk mengonversi sejumlah besar e-bit yang noisy
menjadi jumlah yang lebih kecil
dari e-bit berkualitas tinggi yang kemudian bisa digunakan untuk teleportation tanpa noise atau hampir tanpa noise.
Idenya adalah bahwa proses
entanglement distillation tidak terlalu rumit dalam arti tertentu, kita bisa menerima kerugian dan
jika tidak berhasil,
maka kita bisa mencoba lagi, sedangkan qubit aktual yang
ingin kita komunikasikan mungkin dianggap jauh lebih berharga.
Tentu saja, ini semua spekulasi, tapi intinya adalah bahwa tidak sulit untuk menghipotesiskan situasi
di mana teleportation
bisa menjadi cara yang sangat praktis
untuk mengomunikasikan qubit.
Dan poin terakhir
tentang teleportation adalah bahwa ide di balik teleportation dan cara kerjanya
sangat mendasar
dalam informasi dan komputasi kuantum, teleportation benar-benar merupakan landasan dari teori informasi kuantum dan variasi-variasi
dari ide tersebut juga sering muncul,
ini hanyalah satu contoh, ada proposal untuk
mengimplementasikan berbagai quantum gate
menggunakan teleportation, tapi
di mana state awal dan pengukuran yang berbeda dipilih sehingga hasilnya
adalah menerapkan operasi yang dipilih
daripada berkomunikasi.
Contoh selanjutnya adalah superdense coding.
Seperti quantum teleportation,
superdense coding adalah protokol dan yang dicapainya saling melengkapi dengan teleportation.
Sedangkan teleportation memungkinkan
satu qubit untuk ditransmisikan menggunakan e-bit dan dua
bit klasikal komunikasi,
superdense coding memungkinkan
dua bit klasikal untuk ditransmisikan menggunakan
e-bit dan satu qubit komunikasi kuantum.
Jadi, singkatnya, superdense coding memungkinkan transmisi
informasi klasikal dan alasan ia disebut superdense coding
WEBVTT
adalah karena ia memungkinkan dua
bit klasikal komunikasi dikemas dalam satu qubit,
tapi kita harus menghabiskan
e-bit untuk mencapai ini.
Ini adalah penjelasan
yang lebih tepat tentang pengaturannya.
Sekali lagi, kita punya Alice dan Bob, di mana Alice adalah pengirim
dan Bob adalah penerima, dan kali ini Alice memiliki dua bit klasikal
yang ingin dia kirimkan ke Bob.
Alice dapat mengirimkan satu qubit ke Bob dan Alice serta Bob berbagi
e-bit yang bisa mereka gunakan untuk membantu mereka menyelesaikan tugas mereka,
yaitu agar Bob menerima
dua bit klasikal.
Sekarang, dalam artian tertentu tugas ini mungkin tampak kurang menarik dibanding tugas yang
teleportation capai,
terutama jika kita melihat
bahwa mengirim qubit secara signifikan lebih
sulit atau lebih menantang dibandingkan mengirim bit klasikal,
yang merupakan sudut pandang yang cukup masuk akal tapi memang menarik bahwa itu bisa dilakukan.
Salah satu alasan mengapa itu menarik
adalah bahwa pada kenyataannya tidak mungkin untuk menyelesaikan
tugas transmisi dua bit klasikal informasi ini
menggunakan satu qubit tanpa
menggunakan e-bit.
Kita tahu ini karena teorema terkenal yang dikenal sebagai teorema Holevo.
Teorema Holevo lebih
umum dari ini, dan pernyataan tepat
dari teorema Holevo agak teknis dan
membutuhkan beberapa penjelasan,
tapi salah satu implikasinya
adalah bahwa kamu tidak bisa mentransmisikan sejumlah bit klasikal komunikasi menggunakan lebih sedikit qubit dari
komunikasi kuantum saja.
Kalau kamu ingin mentransmisikan dua bit klasikal informasi secara andal menggunakan qubit dan kamu tidak punya
e-bit untuk digunakan,
kamu harus mengirim dua qubit, jadi mungkin saja langsung simpan bit yang ingin kamu transmisikan di sana.
Alasan lain mengapa superdense
coding menarik adalah karena hubungan komplementer yang erat yang dimilikinya dengan teleportation, dan
kita akan kembali ke ini
sedikit nanti. Ini adalah deskripsi quantum circuit dari protokol superdense coding.
Untuk yang ini, saya tidak akan
mencantumkan semua langkah, tapi sebagai gantinya kita akan tetap menggunakan deskripsi diagram circuit.
Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat, kita lagi
punya Alice dan Bob, di mana Alice ada di atas
dan Bob ada di bawah.
Ini adalah e-bit yang
awalnya dibagi antara Alice dan Bob, yang sudah
entah bagaimana ditetapkan sebelum protokol dijalankan.
Alice punya dua bit klasikal, A dan B, yang bisa kamu lihat di sini
dan melalui protokol yang circuit deskripsikan,
dua bit klasikal ini
akan berakhir di tangan Bob.
Hanya ada satu qubit
yang melintasi garis antara Alice dan Bob, dan tentu saja tidak ada
bit klasikal yang dikirimkan,
transmisi
dua bit klasikal itulah yang menjadi inti protokol.
Kamu juga akan memperhatikan bahwa ia memiliki
komponen yang persis sama yang digunakan dalam teleportation, kita punya controlled NOT
gate, Hadamard gate,
dan Z dan X-gate
yang dikendalikan oleh bit klasikal.
Namun mereka tersusun berbeda, jadi mari kita lanjutkan ke
analisis untuk melihat cara kerjanya.
Untuk menganalisis cara superdense coding bekerja, mari kita mulai dengan menuliskan
Bell basis, yang sangat ada di
jantung analisis.
Yang akan kita lakukan adalah
pertama melihat efek yang tindakan Alice
miliki pada state Phi plus, dan yang akan kita lihat adalah
bahwa Alice mengubah ini
state Phi plus ke salah satu
dari empat Bell state tergantung pada bit
yang ingin dia kirimkan.
Jadi, mari kita tuliskan tabel supaya kita bisa
melacak apa yang sedang terjadi.
Pertama, jika A dan B keduanya nol, maka baik Z-gate maupun
X-gate tidak diterapkan, jadi tindakan Alice tidak melakukan apa-apa,
yang berarti bahwa Phi
plus dipetakan ke Phi plus.
Kita juga bisa mengekspresikan itu sebagai persamaan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
tidak ada yang terjadi pada qubit Alice dan tidak ada yang terjadi pada qubit Bob
dan tidak melakukan apa pun diwakili
oleh matriks identitas.
Sekarang, apa yang terjadi jika A sama dengan nol dan B sama dengan satu?
Karena B sama dengan satu, kita menerapkan Z-gate dan
kita tidak menerapkan X-gate karena A sama dengan nol
dan kita melihat bahwa efek keseluruhan adalah bahwa Alice melakukan Z-gate.
Alice ada di kanan
karena dia ada di atas, meskipun sebenarnya tidak akan membuat perbedaan dalam kasus tertentu
ini, efeknya adalah bahwa
state Phi plus
dipetakan ke Phi minus, yang bisa kamu perkirakan
dari ekspresi-ekspresi ini jika kamu ingat bagaimana Z-gate bekerja.
Jadi, kita bisa menambahkan yang ini ke tabel kita, ada dua kasus lagi yang harus dilalui, jika A sama dengan satu
dan B sama dengan nol,
maka Alice melakukan
X-gate yang mengubah Phi ke Chi plus, dan jika A sama dengan satu
dan B sama dengan satu,
maka Alice melakukan Z, kemudian
X dan kita mendapatkan Chi minus.
Jadi, tabel kita memberi tahu kita apa yang terjadi dalam empat kemungkinan kasus dan itu adalah bahwa Alice secara efektif memilih yang mana
WEBVTT
dari empat Bell state yang ingin dia
bagikan dengan Bob, dan dia punya kebebasan untuk memilih dengan hanya bertindak pada qubitnya saja
dan itu adalah aspek yang cukup menarik
dari entanglement.
Alice kemudian mengirimkan qubitnya
ke Bob, pada titik ini, Bob memegang salah satu dari empat Bell state dan dia hanya perlu
mencari tahu yang mana
untuk memulihkan bit-bitnya.
Dan kita bisa memeriksa bahwa
memang controlled NOT gate diikuti oleh Hadamard gate
seperti yang kita miliki dalam diagram melakukan hal yang benar.
Saya tidak akan membahasnya secara detail, tapi jika kamu memilih untuk melakukan itu, kamu akan menemukan bahwa efeknya adalah
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini dalam tabel.
Salah satu cara untuk memeriksanya
adalah dengan langsung menghitung. Sebagai alternatif, kita bisa mengakui bahwa kita sebenarnya sudah
melalui ini secara terbalik
dalam pelajaran sebelumnya. Dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita
punya Hadamard gate dulu dan controlled NOT gate kedua
dan kita melihat bahwa circuit itu
memetakan state basis standar ke Bell state dengan tanda minus yang menjengkelkan dalam salah satu kasusnya.
Ketika kita membalik urutan gate dan kita mempertimbangkan fakta
bahwa kedua gate ini adalah inversnya sendiri,
yang kita dapatkan adalah inversnya,
dan jadi yang kita miliki dalam
kasus ini adalah aksinya berjalan ke arah berlawanan
dan tanda minus bisa memilih sisi mana pun yang ingin ditempatkan,
tapi selain itu, ia ada di tempatnya, dan pada titik ini langsung jelas bahwa pengukuran mengungkapkan nilai-nilai yang benar,
tanda minus di sini tidak mengganggu kita karena satu muncul dengan
probabilitas satu dalam kasus ini, dan itulah semua yang ada dalam analisis.
Singkatnya, Alice memilih Bell state dan Bob mencari tahu mana itu.
Hanya beberapa catatan singkat
tentang superdense coding sebelum kita lanjutkan; pertama, kita harus mengakui
bahwa superdense coding
mungkin tidak akan berguna atau praktis dalam arti apa pun sebagai cara untuk
mentransmisikan informasi klasikal.
Komunikasi klasikal
sangat murah dan secara fisik mengirimkan qubit itu menantang untuk tidak dibilang lebih,
dan selama itu masih demikian, kita tidak akan mengharapkan keuntungan
praktis sama sekali dari superdense coding.
Tapi hanya karena kemungkinan besar tidak akan praktis bukan berarti superdense
coding tidak menarik.
Ini sangat menarik faktanya, salah satunya, ide yang mendasarinya
sangat fundamental,
dan ketika saya merujuk ke ide yang mendasarinya, maksud saya adalah ide bahwa jika Alice
berbagi Bell state dengan Bob,
maka dia bisa memilih untuk mengubah state itu ke Bell state lain apa pun yang
dia pilih sendirian saja, dia tidak butuh bantuan Bob
sama sekali untuk melakukan itu.
Ini adalah contoh spesifik
yang berkaitan dengan Bell state, tapi ada ide yang lebih umum yang mendasarinya yang berkaitan dengan kebebasan yang satu pemain
miliki untuk mengubah state terjalin yang dibagikan dengan pemain lain, dan memahami tepatnya apa kebebasan itu
adalah langkah penting dalam memahami informasi kuantum dan kita akan melihat tepatnya bagaimana mendeskripsikan kebebasan itu dalam cara yang sederhana
dan elegan dalam
unit ketiga seri.
Superdense coding juga
memberikan contoh konkret tentang apa yang bisa kamu lakukan dengan entanglement, yaitu memungkinkan dua bit klasikal untuk ditransmisikan
dengan mengirimkan satu qubit. Seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan, ini
terbukti tidak mungkin oleh teorema Holevo tanpa entanglement.
Kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan teleportation dan superdense coding bersama-sama, dan kita melihat bahwa keduanya
menetapkan kesetaraan
antara satu qubit komunikasi kuantum dan dua bit komunikasi klasikal.
Selama kamu mau
menghabiskan satu e-bit, kamu bisa secara efektif
mengonversi satu ke yang lain.
Teleportation memungkinkan
komunikasi satu qubit menggunakan dua bit klasikal komunikasi dan superdense coding berjalan ke arah sebaliknya
dan memungkinkan dua bit klasikal
komunikasi menggunakan satu qubit komunikasi kuantum.
Tanpa menghabiskan e-bit, bagaimanapun, kamu tidak bisa mengubah
salah satu menjadi yang lain, entanglement itulah yang
memungkinkan ini.
Contoh ketiga dan terakhir
yang akan kita bahas dalam pelajaran ini bukan sebuah protokol tapi sebuah
permainan yang dikenal sebagai permainan CHSH.
Ketika kita berbicara tentang permainan dalam konteks ini, kita tidak berbicara tentang sesuatu yang dimaksudkan untuk
dimainkan demi kesenangan atau olahraga,
melainkan abstraksi matematis dalam arti teori permainan misalnya.
Abstraksi matematis dari permainan sangat sering dipelajari dalam
ekonomi dan ilmu komputer, misalnya, dan ada
cukup banyak nilai
yang bisa ditemukan dalam abstraksi, jadi permainan tidak semua menyenangkan
ternyata,
meskipun memang menyenangkan untuk memikirkannya.
Dalam kasus tertentu ini, yang kita miliki adalah pada dasarnya
sebuah eksperimen pikiran yang bisa dideskripsikan dengan cara
yang cukup intuitif sebagai permainan.
Huruf-huruf CHSH merujuk ke para penulis, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, dan Richard Holt dari sebuah makalah tahun 1969 di mana contoh tersebut
pertama kali dideskripsikan. Mereka tidak mendeskripsikannya
sebagai permainan, faktanya, dan cukup umum
untuk merujuk ke contoh ini
bukan sebagai permainan CHSH, melainkan
sebagai pertidaksamaan CHSH.
Untuk ilmuwan komputer seperti saya, bagaimanapun, sangat alami
untuk mendeskripsikannya sebagai permainan.
Saya sudah menyarankan bahwa
abstraksi matematis dari permainan keduanya penting dan berguna dan ada banyak kategori permainan yang berbeda
WEBVTT
yang bisa dipertimbangkan. Permainan CHSH adalah
contoh dari kelas permainan yang disebut permainan non-lokal.
Ini adalah pengaturan umum
untuk permainan non-lokal.
Kita punya dua pemain, Alice dan Bob, yang bekerja sama sebagai tim, jadi mereka menang bersama
atau kalah bersama.
Ini berarti bahwa mereka tidak punya
insentif untuk bertindak egois, jadi ini pada dasarnya adalah kebalikan
ekstrem dari permainan zero-sum,
yang murni kompetitif, di sini permainannya murni kooperatif.
Ada entitas ketiga yang disebut wasit.
Wasit bukan pemain dalam permainan, melainkan wasit
menjalankan permainan, dan faktanya, kamu bisa memikirkan spesifikasi
dari instansi tertentu
dari permainan non-lokal dan spesifikasi dari
wasit sebagai setara.
Ada batasan yang sangat penting yang dikenakan pada Alice dan Bob, yaitu bahwa begitu permainan dimulai, mereka dilarang berkomunikasi satu sama lain.
Mereka bisa setuju sebelumnya tentang
strategi apa pun yang mereka pilih, tapi tidak ada komunikasi
yang diperbolehkan di antara mereka selama permainan itu sendiri.
Kalau mau, kamu bisa membayangkan
permainan berlangsung di fasilitas aman semacam itu seolah-olah wasit memainkan
peran detektif
dan Alice dan Bob adalah tersangka yang berada di ruangan berbeda di kantor polisi, tapi cara lain untuk
memikirkan pengaturan tersebut
adalah bahwa Alice dan Bob
dipisahkan oleh jarak yang sangat jauh dan komunikasi dilarang karena kecepatan cahaya
tidak memungkinkan komunikasi
terjadi dengan cukup cepat. Kalau Alice mencoba mengirim pesan ke Bob misalnya, permainan akan berakhir pada
saat Bob menerimanya.
Cara permainan non-lokal
bekerja adalah bahwa pertama, wasit memberikan pertanyaan kepada
Alice dan Bob.
Pertanyaan Alice diberi label X dan pertanyaan Bob diberi label Y.
Secara umum, kamu bisa memikirkan X dan Y sebagai state klasikal
dari state klasikal apa pun yang kamu suka dan dalam
kasus spesifik permainan CHSH,
X dan Y adalah bit.
Alice dan Bob kemudian harus memberikan jawaban, jawaban Alice diberi label A,
dan jawaban Bob diberi label B,
dan lagi, jawaban-jawaban ini bisa dipandang sebagai state klasikal secara umum dan seperti pertanyaan, mereka
akan menjadi bit dalam permainan CHSH.
Pada titik ini, wasit membuat keputusan, Alice dan Bob menang atau kalah tergantung apakah atau tidak
pasangan jawaban A, B
dianggap benar untuk
pasangan pertanyaan X, Y yang wasit tanyakan, dan saya akan mengatakan sedikit lebih
tentang ini dalam sebentar.
Pertama, mari kita lihat lebih dekat
wasit untuk memahami apa yang berpotensi menantang bagi Alice dan Bob dalam permainan non-lokal.
Dan yang membuat permainan non-lokal
berpotensi menantang adalah bahwa wasit bisa menggunakan keacakan untuk memilih pertanyaan X dan Y.
Itu berarti bahwa Alice
dan Bob memiliki ketidakpastian, mereka tidak tahu sebelumnya pertanyaan apa yang akan mereka ditanya, dan mungkin yang lebih penting,
mereka tidak tahu pertanyaan apa
yang diterima oleh yang lain dan ketidakpastian itulah
bersama dengan fakta bahwa mereka tidak bisa berkomunikasi
yang menghadirkan tantangan.
Jadi, ini mirip dengan situasi di mana seorang detektif
menginterogasi dua tersangka di ruangan berbeda, kalau
para tersangka tidak tahu
pertanyaan apa yang ditanyakan kepada yang lainnya, itu jauh lebih sulit jika mereka bersalah untuk menjaga cerita mereka tetap konsisten.
Sekarang, saya menyebutkan beberapa saat lalu bahwa wasit membuat penentuan
bahwa Alice dan Bob sudah menjawab
dengan benar atau tidak benar
tergantung pada pertanyaan
yang ditanyakan kepada mereka.
Diasumsikan bahwa
penentuan ini dibuat sesuai dengan beberapa aturan tetap dan kamu bisa mempertimbangkan aturan apa pun yang kamu inginkan,
tapi apa pun itu,
diasumsikan bahwa Alice
dan Bob mengetahui aturannya, jadi setidaknya mereka punya peluang
untuk menjawab dengan benar.
Kita akan melihat
aturan untuk permainan CHSH dalam sebentar, tapi kita bisa
mempertimbangkan aturan yang berbeda dan kita akan punya contoh
yang berbeda dari permainan non-lokal.
Beberapa permainan non-lokal menarik dan faktanya beberapa sangat menarik dan misterius hingga hari ini dan
beberapa tidak begitu menarik,
itulah sifat dari
model permainan non-lokal.
Bagaimanapun, ini adalah dua hal berbeda yang diperlukan untuk mendeskripsikan wasit; bagaimana tepatnya pertanyaan dipilih
dan pasangan jawaban mana yang benar untuk setiap kemungkinan pasangan pertanyaan.
Kalau kita punya deskripsi
dari dua hal itu, maka kita punya deskripsi untuk wasit dan itu secara efektif mendeskripsikan
sebuah instansi dari permainan non-lokal.
Sekarang mari kita lihat
permainan CHSH secara khusus.
Cara permainan didefinisikan atau, secara ekuivalen, bagaimana wasit didefinisikan adalah sebagai berikut;
pertama, seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan, pertanyaan dan jawabannya semuanya bit, jadi wasit mengirimkan bit X
ke Alice dan bit Y ke Bob,
dan mereka masing-masing merespons dengan sebuah bit. Alice merespons dengan A
dan Bob merespons dengan B.
Cara wasit memilih
pertanyaan mana yang akan ditanyakan itu sederhana, dia memilihnya secara seragam acak,
jadi, pasangan pertanyaan X, Y sama-sama mungkin menjadi salah satu
dari empat kemungkinan, nol, nol, nol, satu,
satu, nol, dan satu, satu.
Terakhir, aturan yang
menentukan jawaban mana yang menang dan mana yang kalah adalah
bahwa pasangan jawaban A, B benar untuk pasangan pertanyaan X, Y
WEBVTT
jika dan hanya jika exclusive or dari A dan B sama dengan logical and dari X dan Y.
Itu mungkin sedikit lebih mudah dicerna jika kita mengekspresikan kondisi-kondisi itu
dalam bentuk tabel seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dalam kolom pertama, kita punya empat kemungkinan pasangan pertanyaan, dan dalam kolom kedua kita
punya kondisi pada A dan B
yang diperlukan agar
Alice dan Bob menang.
Dalam tiga kasus pertama,
and dari A dan Y adalah nol, jadi exclusive or harus sama dengan nol
agar mereka menang,
dan itu sama dengan mengatakan bahwa A dan B harus sama karena A dan B adalah bit,
dan kasus keempat,
and dari X dan Y sama
dengan satu dan jadi exclusive or dari A dan B harus sama dengan satu agar Alice dan Bob menang
dan itu sama dengan
mengatakan bahwa A dan B harus berbeda.
Jadi, itulah permainan CHSH, dan sekarang kita bisa memikirkan
berbagai strategi yang mungkin untuk Alice dan Bob dan seberapa baik mereka bisa melakukannya dalam permainan ini.
Mari kita mulai dengan memikirkan
strategi deterministik di mana jawaban Alice A adalah
fungsi dari pertanyaan X yang dia terima, dan
begitu pula, jawaban Bob B
adalah fungsi dari
pertanyaan Y yang dia terima.
Dan ternyata, tidak ada
strategi deterministik yang bisa menang setiap saat.
Salah satu cara untuk berargumen demikian adalah
dengan langsung menjalaninya satu per satu melalui semua kemungkinan
strategi deterministik dan memeriksa bahwa setiap satu di antaranya kalah
untuk setidaknya satu dari empat
kemungkinan pasangan pertanyaan.
Alice dan Bob, masing-masing punya
empat kemungkinan fungsi untuk dipilih, kita melihat
empat fungsi itu dalam pelajaran satu, jadi ada 16 kemungkinan
untuk diperiksa secara keseluruhan.
Cara lain untuk melihatnya adalah dengan
memikirkan persamaan-persamaan di layar di sini, kita sedang memikirkan strategi deterministik
di mana A dan B adalah fungsi
dari X dan Y masing-masing.
Jadi misalnya, A dari nol
mewakili jawaban Alice ketika pertanyaannya X sama dengan nol dan a dari satu mewakili jawaban Alice
ketika pertanyaannya X sama dengan satu.
Ini adalah empat persamaan
yang harus benar agar kondisi kemenangan
terpenuhi di masing-masing dari empat kasus.
Misalnya, jika X sama dengan
nol dan Y sama dengan nol, maka exclusive or dari A
dan B harus sama dengan nol,
sedangkan dalam kasus bahwa X sama dengan satu dan Y sama dengan satu,
exclusive or dari A dan B harus sama dengan satu.
Salah satu cara kita bisa melihat bahwa
tidak ada cara untuk memilih fungsi A dan B sehingga
persamaan-persamaan ini semua benar, adalah dengan langsung mengambil exclusive or dari semua persamaan.
Exclusive or dari nilai biner
apa pun dengan dirinya sendiri sama dengan nol, dan jadi berikut bahwa exclusive or
dari sisi kiri
sama dengan nol, itu
karena kita punya dua instansi dari a nol, dua instansi dari a satu,
dua instansi dari B nol
dan dua instansi dari B satu.
Jadi, meng-xor semua bersama-sama
memberikan kita jawaban akhir nol, tapi jika kita mengambil exclusive or dari sisi kanan persamaan,
kita mendapatkan satu bukan nol. Jadi keempat persamaan
tidak mungkin semuanya benar, setidaknya satu di antaranya harus salah
dan itu akan menyebabkan
kekalahan bagi Alice dan Bob dalam setidaknya satu dari empat kasus.
Dan jadi berikut karena wasit memilih pertanyaan
secara seragam bahwa probabilitas bagi Alice dan Bob untuk menang
menggunakan strategi deterministik
adalah paling banyak tiga perempat atau 75%.
Fakta bahwa Alice dan Bob bisa menang dengan probabilitas tiga perempat cukup mudah dilihat
sebenarnya, kalau Alice dan Bob keduanya menjawab nol setiap saat, misalnya,
mereka akan benar tiga
dari empat kali.
Jadi Alice dan Bob tidak bisa
berbuat lebih baik dari menang 75% dari waktu menggunakan
strategi deterministik.
Tapi bagaimana dengan strategi probabilistik?
Ternyata menggunakan
strategi probabilistik tidak bisa membantu mereka sama sekali, itu karena setiap
strategi probabilistik
secara alternatif bisa dipandang
sebagai pemilihan acak dari strategi deterministik seperti operasi probabilistik bisa dipandang
sebagai pemilihan acak dari
operasi deterministik, seperti yang kita lihat dalam pelajaran pertama.
Rata-rata tidak pernah
lebih besar dari maksimum, jadi berikut bahwa
strategi probabilistik tidak menawarkan keuntungan apa pun dalam hal menang
dibanding strategi deterministik. Ini bahkan termasuk kemungkinan bahwa pilihan acak Alice dan Bob berkorelasi.
Jadi, intinya adalah bahwa menang dengan probabilitas tiga perempat adalah yang terbaik yang bisa dilakukan Alice
dan Bob menggunakan strategi klasikal apa pun,
baik deterministik
maupun probabilistik.
Pertanyaan alami untuk diajukan pada titik ini adalah apakah Alice dan Bob bisa berbuat lebih baik menggunakan strategi kuantum,
dan khususnya
kalau mereka berbagi state kuantum terjalin yang bisa sudah mereka siapkan
sebelum bermain, bisakah itu membantu mereka?
Jawabannya adalah ya, bisa, dan itulah inti dari contoh ini dan itulah mengapa ini begitu menarik.
Jadi mari kita lihat secara tepat bagaimana
Alice dan Bob bisa berbuat lebih baik dalam permainan ini menggunakan entanglement.
WEBVTT
Hal pertama yang perlu kita lakukan adalah mendefinisikan vektor state kuantum Chi
theta untuk setiap sudut theta, seperti yang bisa kamu lihat di sini di layar.
Jadi, Chi theta sama dengan
kosinus theta kali ket nol plus sinus theta kali ket
satu, dan di sini ngomong-ngomong,
kita sedang memikirkan
sudut dalam hal radian.
Jadi misalnya, inilah vektor yang kita dapatkan ketika theta sama dengan pi per
empat, yaitu 45 derajat.
Kosinus dari pi per empat
dan sinus dari pi per empat keduanya sama dengan satu per
akar kuadrat dua, jadi ini hanyalah nama lain
untuk state plus.
Ini adalah contoh lain ketika theta sama dengan tiga kali pi per delapan, dan jika kamu tidak
kebetulan tahu sinus
dan kosinus dari tiga kali pi per delapan dari ingatan,
inilah tabel sinus dan kosinus yang sebenarnya akan kita perlukan
sepanjang contoh ini
dan mencakup yang kita butuhkan untuk vektor tertentu ini.
Sekarang, kalau kita mau mengambil inner product antara dua dari vektor-vektor ini
untuk sudut, alpha dan beta katakanlah, mudah untuk melakukan itu.
Kita hanya punya entri bilangan riil
dalam vektor-vektor ini sehingga tidak ada
konjugat kompleks yang perlu dikhawatirkan dan kita mendapatkan produk dari kosinus-kosinus
plus produk dari sinus-sinusnya, dan kita bisa menggunakan salah satu dari
rumus penambahan sudut yang disebut
untuk menyederhanakannya, yaitu
kosinus dari selisih antara sudut-sudut dan
karena fungsi kosinus
simetris di sekitar nol,
sebenarnya tidak masalah urutan mana yang kita ambil.
Kalau kamu tidak punya identitas trigonometri semacam itu
dalam ingatan ngomong-ngomong,
kamu tidak sendirian, tapi kamu tidak harus mengingatnya,
kamu tinggal carinya. Yang satu ini memang masuk akal
ketika kamu memikirkan interpretasi geometris
dari inner product
antara vektor satuan riil sebagai kosinus dari sudut di antara keduanya.
Jika kita menghitung inner product
dari tensor product dari dua vektor mana pun dengan state Phi plus, kita mendapatkan ekspresi yang tampak serupa
kecuali bahwa ada akar kuadrat
dua di penyebutnya.
Ini adalah pertama kalinya
state Phi plus muncul dalam konteks
contoh ini ngomong-ngomong, dan kita akan melihat tepatnya mengapa kita tertarik
pada inner product tertentu ini segera, tapi untuk saat ini mari kita
hanya perhatikan bahwa kita mendapatkan ekspresi yang sama yang kita miliki
untuk inner product dibagi
dengan akar kuadrat dua dan jadi kita bisa menyederhanakan seperti sebelumnya.
Selanjutnya, kita akan mendefinisikan
matriks uniter, U theta, untuk setiap sudut theta
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
tidak sulit untuk
memeriksa bahwa ini memang matriks uniter.
Hal penting yang perlu kita
ketahui adalah bahwa vektor si theta ortogonal terhadap
vektor si theta plus pi per dua, dan itu masuk akal
karena jika kita memutar sebesar pi per dua, yaitu 90 derajat, kita
mendapatkan vektor yang ortogonal.
Jika kita kemudian mengalikan U
theta dengan U theta dagger, kita mendapatkan matriks identitas.
Secara intuitif,
apa yang matriks ini lakukan sebagai operasi adalah memetakan si theta ke ket nol dan si theta plus pi dua ke ket satu.
Pada titik ini, kita punya
semua yang kita butuhkan untuk mendeskripsikan strategi Alice dan Bob.
Pertama, seperti yang kita miliki untuk teleportation dan superdense coding, Alice dan Bob akan mulai dengan berbagi e-bit.
Alice memegang qubit A,
Bob memegang qubit B, dan bersama-sama dua qubit
berada dalam state Phi plus.
Tindakan Alice adalah sebagai berikut; dia melihat bit X yang
dia terima dari wasit,
dan jika X sama dengan nol,
dia melakukan U nol pada A, yang kebetulan sama dengan tidak melakukan apa-apa karena U nol adalah matriks identitas,
jika X sama dengan satu di sisi lain, dia menerapkan U pi per empat ke A.
Setelah dia menerapkan salah satu
dari dua operasi, dia mengukur A menggunakan
pengukuran basis standar dan mengirimkan hasil apa pun yang dia dapatkan ke wasit.
Bob melakukan sesuatu yang sangat mirip, qubitnya disebut B tentu saja, dan dia menerima Y dari wasit sebagai lawan dari X
tapi perbedaan utamanya adalah
bahwa dia menggunakan sudut yang berbeda untuk operasi unitarnya.
Jika Y sama dengan nol, dia
menerapkan U pi per delapan, dan jika Y sama dengan satu, dia menerapkan u negatif pi per delapan.
Dan kita akan melihat mengapa pilihan sudut-sudut ini adalah pilihan yang bagus segera,
sama sekali tidak jelas.
Dan inilah diagram circuit
yang mengekspresikan strategi ini.
Bob ada di atas dan Alice
ada di bawah kali ini, inilah e-bit yang masuk
dan ini adalah gate uniter
yang Alice dan Bob mungkin atau mungkin tidak terapkan
tergantung pada apa X dan Y.
Untuk yang satu ini dan yang satu ini, kita punya gate yang dikendalikan baik oleh bit X maupun bit Y
dan untuk kedua yang ini di sini, kita punya apa yang terlihat seperti control gate kecuali bahwa lingkarannya tidak terisi.
Dan artinya adalah
bahwa jika bit kontrol diset ke nol, maka gate dilakukan dan jika kontrol diset ke
satu, maka tidak ada yang terjadi.
Jadi, ini seperti
control gate biasa kecuali bahwa peran nol dan satu untuk kontrol ditukar.
Jadi, secara efektif, Bob
melakukan gate ini di sini jika Y sama dengan nol, dia
melakukan gate ini di sini
WEBVTT
jika Y sama dengan satu, dan begitu pula, Alice melakukan gate ini di sini
jika X sama dengan nol, dan gate ini di sini,
jika X sama dengan satu.
Jadi, itulah strategi Alice dan Bob dan sekarang kita hanya perlu
mencari tahu seberapa baik ia bekerja.
Untuk analisis strategi kuantum yang baru saja saya deskripsikan, kita
benar-benar hanya membutuhkan dua hal pada titik ini, pertama, matriks uniter U Theta
adalah seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, dan
kedua kita punya rumus ini.
Kita sebenarnya bahkan tidak perlu lagi definisi vektor si theta, dua persamaan ini adalah semua yang kita butuhkan.
Ada empat kasus yang perlu
dipertimbangkan dimulai dengan kasus satu, yaitu X sama
dengan nol dan Y sama dengan nol.
Dan jika kita melihat kembali strateginya, kita akan menemukan bahwa dalam
kasus ini Alice melakukan U nol pada qubitnya dan Bob melakukan
U pi per delapan pada qubitnya.
Ingat, Alice ada di
bawah dan Bob ada di atas, jadi state yang mereka
dapatkan terlihat seperti ini.
Dan dengan memperluas itu
sesuai definisi U theta, kita mendapatkan
ekspresi yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita tidak perlu memperluas
itu lebih lanjut karena kita punya rumus lain
untuk membantu kita.
Dan jika kita menerapkan rumus itu
untuk masing-masing dari empat suku, yang kita dapatkan adalah ini.
Pada titik ini Alice dan Bob keduanya mengukur dan inilah tabel yang
menjelaskan distribusi hasilnya.
Kita mengambil nilai absolut
kuadrat dari koefisien untuk mendapatkan probabilitas, yang kebetulan adalah
kuadrat dari koefisien
karena koefisiennya semuanya
bilangan riil dalam kasus ini.
Jika kita menggunakan
nilai sinus dan kosinus dari sebelumnya dalam pelajaran
bersama dengan beberapa simetri, kita bisa mengekspresikan probabilitas-probabilitas ini seperti yang kita miliki di sini
dalam kolom terakhir.
Sekarang, yang benar-benar kita pedulikan
adalah probabilitas bahwa mereka menang, dan ingat bahwa, dalam kasus bahwa X dan Y keduanya nol,
mereka menang jika A dan B sama dan mereka kalah jika A dan B tidak sama.
Jika kita menghitung probabilitas-probabilitas itu, kita menemukan bahwa probabilitas
bahwa A dan B sama adalah jumlah dari angka ini dan angka ini,
yang sama dengan dua ditambah
akar dua semua dibagi empat, yang sekitar 85%.
Probabilitas bahwa A dan B tidak sama adalah dua dikurangi akar dua semua dibagi empat, yang secara alami satu dikurangi kuantitas
yang baru saja kita hitung, jadi
mereka menang dengan probabilitas sekitar 85% dalam kasus ini.
Ada tiga kasus lagi yang perlu dipertimbangkan, tapi semuanya sangat mirip dengan yang satu ini,
dalam kasus bahwa X sama dengan
nol dan Y sama dengan satu, Bob menerapkan U negatif pi per delapan daripada U pi per delapan,
nilai-nilai dalam
rumus-rumus berubah agak, tapi kita berakhir dengan
probabilitas yang persis sama yang kita miliki dalam kasus sebelumnya.
Ketika X sama dengan nol dan Y sama dengan satu, Alice dan Bob masih menang
ketika A dan B sama dan jadi kita punya probabilitas kemenangan yang persis sama
seperti sebelumnya.
Dalam kasus ketiga, ketika X sama dengan satu dan Y sama dengan nol, kita
punya situasi yang mirip, sudut-sudutnya berbeda,
tapi keduanya memiliki
hubungan yang persis sama satu sama lain, dan faktanya, kita memang mendapatkan
vektor yang persis sama yang kita dapatkan dalam kasus sebelumnya.
Jadi probabilitasnya sama dan begitu pula probabilitas kemenangan.
Kasus terakhir sedikit
berbeda seperti yang mungkin kita harapkan karena kondisi kemenangan
berbeda dalam kasus ini.
Ketika X dan Y keduanya sama dengan satu, Alice dan Bob menang ketika
A dan B berbeda.
Metode dasarnya sama, meskipun sudut-sudutnya berbeda, kali ini, kita mendapatkan vektor ini di sini
dan kamu bisa memeriksanya dengan menjalani pengurangan-pengurangan yang diperlukan.
Probabilitas-probabilitas memang berubah akhirnya, dan jika kita mencari nilai-nilai yang kita butuhkan, kita melihat bahwa probabilitas-probabilitasnya secara efektif
telah bertukar posisi dari sebelumnya, jadi kali ini probabilitas
bahwa A tidak sama dengan B adalah yang lebih besar di antara keduanya,
tapi itu bagus karena dalam kasus ini, Alice dan Bob menang ketika
A dan B tidak sama.
Jadi sekali lagi, mereka menang dengan
probabilitas sekitar 85%.
Mengingat bahwa mereka menang di setiap
kasus dengan probabilitas yang sama, yaitu dua ditambah akar dua
semua dibagi empat atau sekitar 85%,
itulah probabilitas
bahwa mereka menang secara keseluruhan.
Itu lebih baik dari strategi klasikal apa pun yang bisa dilakukan untuk permainan ini, dan itulah
yang membuatnya menarik.
Ini kebetulan adalah
probabilitas kemenangan optimal untuk strategi kuantum apa pun, kamu
tidak bisa berbuat lebih baik dari ini menggunakan state terjalin apa pun.
Fakta itu dikenal sebagai pertidaksamaan Tsirelson, namanya diambil dari Boris
Tsirelson yang pertama kali membuktikannya, dan sepanjang pengetahuan saya adalah
salah satu orang pertama
yang mendeskripsikan contoh ini sebagai permainan. Jika analisis
yang baru saja kita lalui tampak sedikit misterius,
ada kemungkinan untuk memikirkannya
secara geometris, yang mungkin membantu
memberi kamu pemahaman yang lebih baik tentang pilihan sudut-sudut itu.
Khususnya, jika kita menggunakan
rumus yang kamu lihat di sini, yang bisa dengan mudah kita deduksi
dari ekspresi-ekspresi
yang sudah kita temukan untuk
inner product yang terlibat, maka kita bisa secara alternatif
mengekspresikan probabilitas dari berbagai kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran
WEBVTT
dalam empat kasus sebagai berikut; pertama, jika X, Y sama dengan nol, nol, maka inilah probabilitas
dari berbagai hasil pengukuran, dan kamu harus baik memikirkan kembali atau melihat kembali analisis
yang baru saja kita lalui untuk menyimpulkan hal itu menggunakan rumus kita.
Di sini, kita bisa melihat
vektor-vektor state yang berbeda digambar seperti sebelumnya, dan pengkodean warna di sini
adalah bahwa biru berkorespondensi
ke hasil nol dan merah
berkorespondensi ke hasil satu.
Kamu bisa melihat bahwa sudut
antara vektor-vektor biru dan sudut antara vektor-vektor merah
relatif kecil,
yaitu pi per delapan dalam kedua kasus, jadi kosinusnya relatif besar, dan itu berarti bahwa probabilitas bahwa dua hasil
itu sama relatif besar.
Dalam kasus bahwa X, Y sama dengan nol, satu, ini adalah situasi yang mirip, sudut-sudut antara vektor-vektor dengan warna yang sama kecil,
jadi probabilitas dari
hasil yang sama sekali lagi, relatif besar.
Kasus ketiga serupa, dan dalam kasus keempat
ketika X, Y sama dengan satu, satu, sesuatu yang menarik terjadi,
kali ini, hanya berdasarkan cara,
vektor-vektor ini telah dipilih, kita melihat bahwa sudut-sudut antara
vektor-vektor dengan warna yang sama
relatif besar, dan khususnya sudut-sudutnya adalah tiga kali
pi per delapan dalam kedua kasus.
Ini berarti bahwa probabilitas
bahwa hasil pengukurannya sama relatif kecil, tapi ini adalah satu kasus
di mana Alice dan Bob menang
ketika jawaban mereka tidak sama,
jadi itulah yang kita inginkan.
Sekali lagi, inilah vektor-vektornya: ketika X, Y sama dengan nol, nol,
ketika X, Y sama dengan nol, satu,
ketika X, Y sama dengan satu, nol,
dan ketika X, Y sama dengan satu, satu.
Dan mungkin gambar geometris ini membantu dalam membangun beberapa intuisi
tentang bagaimana strategi ini bekerja
dan mengapa berbagai sudut ini dipilih dengan cara yang mereka pilih.
Untuk mengakhiri pelajaran, saya akan membuat beberapa catatan singkat
tentang permainan CHSH.
Pertama, seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan, contoh ini tidak selalu
dideskripsikan sebagai permainan.
Dalam komunitas fisika, misalnya, lebih umum bahwa
contoh tersebut dideskripsikan hanya sebagai eksperimen daripada permainan
dan Alice dan Bob dipandang sebagai detektor daripada pemain.
Ide dasar dari eksperimen seperti ini di mana entanglement menghasilkan
hasil statistik yang tidak konsisten dengan
deskripsi klasikal apa pun
atau lebih umumnya teori
apa pun yang berdasarkan variabel tersembunyi lokal yang disebut,
disebabkan oleh John Bell, yang namanya diabadikan sebagai Bell state,
dan jadi orang-orang sering merujuk
ke eksperimen semacam ini sebagai uji Bell.
Kadang orang juga
merujuk ke teorema Bell, yang bisa dirumuskan dalam berbagai cara, tapi pada dasarnya mengatakan bahwa mekanika kuantum
tidak kompatibel dengan teori variabel tersembunyi lokal yang disebut.
Permainan atau pertidaksamaan CHSH pada dasarnya adalah contoh yang sangat bagus dan bersih
dari uji Bell,
dan kamu bisa memikirkan
contoh ini sebagai bukti atau demonstrasi dari teorema Bell.
Catatan kedua adalah bahwa permainan CHSH menawarkan kita satu cara untuk secara eksperimental menguji bahwa teori informasi kuantum
adalah teori yang akurat. Kita sebenarnya bisa menyiapkan eksperimen yang mengimplementasikan permainan CHSH,
termasuk jenis
strategi berdasarkan entanglement yang baru saja saya deskripsikan, dan
melihat apakah itu bekerja, dan memang bekerja.
Ini memberi kita
tingkat kepercayaan yang tinggi bahwa entanglement itu nyata, dan tidak seperti cara mungkin
yang samar atau puitis
yang kita coba gunakan untuk menjelaskan entanglement, permainan atau eksperimen CHSH
memberi kita cara yang konkret
dan dapat diuji untuk mengamati entanglement.
Kalau itu kedengarannya penting,
itu karena memang penting, dan Hadiah Nobel Fisika 2022
mengakui tepat hal ini.
Hadiah diberikan kepada
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, yang merupakan C dalam CHSH, dan Anton Zeilinger
untuk eksperimen dengan foton terjalin yang menetapkan pelanggaran
pertidaksamaan Bell, atau dengan kata lain, yang
menunjukkan bahwa strategi kuantum
dari jenis yang saya deskripsikan benar-benar bekerja dan mengungguli strategi klasikal.
Dan jika kamu tertarik untuk
mempelajari lebih lanjut tentang ini, saya mendorong kamu untuk melihat
video tentang Teorema Bell oleh kolega saya Olivia Lanes,
langsung di channel YouTube Qiskit.
Dan terakhir, topik
permainan non-lokal secara lebih umum benar-benar menarik, dan itu
adalah area penelitian yang aktif
yang menyatukan
fisika, ilmu komputer, dan matematika murni dan masih banyak
pertanyaan menarik
tentang permainan non-lokal yang
masih belum terjawab hingga hari ini.
Dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran empat, sekaligus akhir dari
unit satu seri tentang Dasar-Dasar Informasi Kuantum.
Pelajaran pertama menjelaskan
bagaimana informasi kuantum bekerja untuk sistem tunggal yang terisolasi, dan pelajaran kedua menjelaskan bagaimana informasi kuantum
bekerja untuk sistem ganda,
yang cukup alami muncul dari cara kerjanya untuk sistem tunggal.
WEBVTT
Pelajaran ketiga memperkenalkan
model quantum circuit dari komputasi, dan dalam pelajaran keempat, kita melihat tiga contoh penting
yang mengilustrasikan hal-hal yang bisa
kita lakukan dengan entanglement.
Di sepanjang jalan, kita melihat beberapa konsep matematika yang sangat penting,
termasuk tensor product dan inner product, dan kita mengamati
beberapa keterbatasan mendasar
dari informasi kuantum.
Saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
unit berikutnya dari seri, yang akan membahas algoritma kuantum, di mana kita akan fokus pada pertanyaan
tentang keunggulan komputasi apa
yang informasi kuantum tawarkan.
Sampai jumpa lagi.